Here are the best drugstore
products I tested in 2022.
Let's start with face products.
The ELF Power Grip primer creates
a really nice tacky base for foundation
that's meant to make
your makeup last longer.
My foundation blended out
really nicely on top of this,
and I do think my makeup
lasted really well,
even my blush, which is literally always
the first thing to disappear on my face.
The ELF Halo Glow Liquid
Filter is a great dupe
for the Charlotte Tilbury Flawless Filter.
It gives you a really glowy
your-skin-but-better base.
These Versed Mood Lighting
Luminizing Glow Drops
are a similar product.
They do give a beautiful glow to the skin,
but they don't really have any coverage.
They do have a lot of
great skincare ingredients
that made my skin feel
really nice and hydrated.
This ELF luminous putty bronzer goes
from this putty formula to a powder.
Up close, you can see a
lot of shimmer in this,
but it doesn't look that way on the skin.
This is one of the most blendable bronzers
I've ever tried, and it brings
a really natural warmth to the skin.
Milani's Conceal + Perfect contour
and highlighter are really good.
These kind of feel like
a drugstore version
of the Charlotte Tilbury wands.
The contour blended
out really beautifully,
and the highlighter gave a pretty glow
without emphasizing my texture.
The ELF Halo Glow powder puff
has become a staple product for me.
It does pick up a lot of product,
but this sets makeup so beautifully,
and it's such great quality.
Like, you wouldn't think this is $4.
The Jason Wu Beauty blush trio
is more on the pricey
side of the drugstore,
but I think it's so worth it.
The blushes all blend out so easily
and look so smooth on the skin.
The color payoff on these is also great.
Moving on to eye products,
this Jason Wu Beauty Flora 4 palette
was surprisingly pigmented
and easy to blend.
Also, this jewel stick was incredible.
Look how much it brightened
up my inner corners.
The ELF Lash 'N Roll mascara
really coats every single lash.
My lashes are so straight,
but this gave them a nice curl.
I wish it thickened my
lashes more, but for 6 bucks,
this is a really good drugstore mascara.
These NYX Jumbo Lash lashes
are so easy to apply,
and the band is really comfortable.
I think these have totally convinced me
to wear lashes more often.
The NYX Thick It Stick It brow gel
is a thickening brow mascara.
If you look really close, you can see
those little fibers that are supposed to
make your brows look fluffier.
I really like the natural full-brow effect
you get with this.
Next, let's talk about lip products.
This is the Maybelline
Super Stay Vinyl Ink
Longwear No-Budge liquid lipcolor.
This is a long-wearing lipstick
that's meant to stay shiny.
You have to shake it for
five seconds, then apply.
Even though I did get a little transfer
and the shine isn't
long-lasting, the lipstick
itself stays super
bright and doesn't budge.
These are the L'Oréal
Colour Riche Intense Volume
matte lipsticks.
The color payoff on these is so good,
and they apply really smoothly.
This is one of the most
comfortable matte formulas
I've ever tried, especially
from the drugstore.
The Jason Wu Extra Pout lip plumper
is a holy-grail product for me.
Even if you don't care about
the lip-pluming aspect,
this is one of the best lip-gloss formulas
I've ever tried.
It's so cushiony and shiny and amazing,
and everyone should get it.
This ELF Cookies 'n Dreams lip gloss
in Cookie Dreams is a black
lip gloss with a bunch
of pretty blue and silver
glitter throughout.
On its own, it gives a bluish-black tint.
I love it more over other lip products.
It's really good for deepening colors,
and the formula of the gloss itself
is actually really nice
for the $4 price point.
I only tested one hair product this year,
and that was the Eco
Styler Unicorn Glitter Gel.
It's a translucent pink color
with blue iridescent sparkles.
Running this through my hair,
you don't really get the glittery effect.
You can see the glitter and color better
when I apply it to
brushed-back straight hair.
This is so cute for a
little glitter moment
every once in a while,
and it actually washed
out of my hair easily.